welcome everyone
happy monday um and welcome everybody
back from break here at the school of
forest for environmental studies and
everyone else from across campus who
just finished up at school of management
i know people have been rapidly in
classes for the last couple of the last
week so i hope fall 2 is going well
welcome as well to everyone online
particularly all the member schools from
the global network for advanced
management uh a consortium of 23 uh
business schools from around the world
that are working on issues that that cut
across borders that really focus on
ways that we can collaborate in a global
economy and this is one of those issues
particularly on sustainability and
business in the environment which is
which is a pillar of that collaboration
um a little bit about this speaker
series um first my name is stuart decu
i'm the program director at the yale
center for business and the environment
a joint initiative between the school of
management and the school of forestry
and environmental studies
this is a the second talk we've had this
year in the ge colloquium in
sustainability leadership
this is established with the support of
the ge foundation to provide
practitioners and thought leaders a
forum to speak about the challenges and
opportunities of implementing
sustainability within their respective
organizations and at a broader scale
the series is open to the public and
offered online and
through the yale youtube channel
in particular again we'd like to thank
everybody tuning in online uh from our
global partner schools um this uh i'll
let um i'm gonna introduce our moderator
and our moderator brad gentry we'll
introduce our speaker for today um we're
thrilled uh on a number of reasons for
on a number of levels to have um
representatives from interbrand here
you're going to brattle introduce emma
but we at yale through the yale center
for business and the environment and the
yale center for customer insights have
been involved in a partnership with
inner brand over the course of the past
year to develop
conferences to really figure out ways
that we can work and bridge that that
divide between academia and
practitioners out in the world
interbrand's been a wonderful partner in
that regard we have a conference on
november 20th at the yale club of new
york uh on sustainability marketing the
power of true stories which we've been
working on with inner brand for the
course of the past year um so we're
thrilled to have them here um
introducing brad brad gentry is the
faculty director of the yale center for
business and the environment and a
professor in practice at both the school
of management and the school of forestry
and environmental studies
and one of the reasons that it's so
appropriate that brad moderates this
talk is uh you know we've focused this
series over the course this first
semester on really global perspectives
people who can speak about these issues
across borders and really understanding
what's happening
at the highest level and sort of the
changes around business and the
environment thought leadership there
brad is developing the first online
course from yale which will be delivered
um to a global this global network of
schools that i mentioned this pilot
online course is called natural capital
risks and opportunities and global
resource systems and it'll run from
january to may of this coming semester
and really focus on the experience of
six multinational companies that are
dealing with resource challenges around
the globe and really understanding and
picking that apart from the science the
technology the business principles the
risks and opportunities associated with
those and so
as a component of that brad's really
working to help us convene a
conversation about some of these issues
at a global level
and with that i'll introduce brad to
introduce our speaker
thank you very much stuart i'm glad to
have you all here today and
we're extremely pleased to have emma
rustic with us today
she's the global director brand
intelligence at inner brand
and her work really focuses on helping
clients understand
how their brands create value
and how to achieve sustainable growth
through their branding
activities
one of the cool things about emma's work
is that it really does try to leverage
data
that then can be used in models that
marry both brand perception and
financial impact
prior to joining inner brand emma was it
that in the consumer electronics
practice uh at ernst at young and
rubicon where they've developed
something called the brand asset
valuator and one of emma's work jobs was
to help in the redesign of that model
based on linkages between changes in
brands images and companies financial
performance
she's seen this in practice across a
wide range of clients the list is long i
won't read them all but from hp to
tiffany's and from the new york times to
harley-davidson so i think we have a
useful representative sample here
she has an mba from columbia and an m.a
in political science from nyu
and we look forward to hearing more
about interbrand's work linking
perception and performance in the
sustainability space
thank you and thank you so much for
having me it's it's truly inspirational
to be on on the campus here and to see
this building i i think it
really speaks to yale's commitment to
sustainability
and thanks for uh being willing to
listen about our ranking i hopefully uh
you looked it up a little bit already so
i assume that there is some background
knowledge uh we as interbrands believe
that brains have a responsibility
to to not only their shareholders but
really all the stakeholders that they
operate and uh the ranking that i'm
going to talk about the best global
greens
green brand ranking is something that
we've published for three years now
thank you
and we started the first ranking uh was
published in
2011 but obviously we started uh
thinking about that a lot sooner and i
wanted to give you a little bit of a
background about why we measure green
prints so the world in uh 2010 wasn't
hugely different from what you know
today uh
some things were
a little bit tougher we were still
recovering from the financial crisis and
the issue of trust in brands was
something that was really big
across categories obviously in financial
services but but really going beyond
that uh this notion of consumers getting
a lot more engaged with brands and
really wanting to know what the brands
are doing wanting to be part of that is
something that was already present and
obviously still very much with us and
not really going away and and the fact
that we live in a digital world where
it's very very easy to exchange
information where it's very uh easy to
to come up with news and it's very
difficult to hide things is something
that uh really encouraged us to think
about
how our brains be how should brands
evolve their behavior because the world
was obviously changing and the brands
are adopting but but not necessarily to
the extent uh that we'd like them to see
and we've we've been seeing studies like
this and numbers like this where uh
people say they really care about the
environment uh we did a study of our own
in 2010 where we looked at not just
whether people say they care about the
environment but we try to derive whether
that care actually translates into
desire to purchase products not just say
that you would buy greener products but
the actual impact on that and we found
out that it does and it does play a role
both in b2c and b2b space not
necessarily the role as big as some
as people like to say if uh if the role
was as big as people state the green
products would be flying off the shelves
a lot faster than they really are uh but
we felt that all of this was adding up
to really a notion that we need to know
more about
what are brands doing and what should
they be doing uh and we knew that uh
there's already a lot of research in the
marketplace we there were rankings that
already existed there were ways of
measuring the impact on
sustainability and what we wanted to add
to that conversation wasn't necessarily
a better way of measuring the the impact
of co2 emissions we are a branding
consultancy we were not going to come up
with a better way of measuring uh some
of those impacts but we felt it was very
important to one measure that impact but
then also understand how to behave as a
brand in that context uh and we we
decided to start from uh the territory
that was very familiar to us we publish
uh best global brands every year we
publish the ranking of the 100 best
global brands uh based on their of the
value of their brand and and we know
that these brands these hundred brands
are already doing an amazing job these
companies and brands are truly global uh
that's one of the criteria that allows
them to qualify for our studies so they
operate not in just one or two regions
they operate around the globe and they
know i think what though about branding
if they're capable of making this list
and being one of the most valuable
brands clearly they know how to deal
with consumers around the globe they
know how to deal with different
environments and they know how to
promote their brains and with all that's
the right point to to start at
what if we think about the brains that
are already smart about all these things
what can be learned about what they're
doing in in the sustainability space
and so that was the starting point for
the methodology
and the other piece that inspired us was
again part of how we think about valuing
brains one of the elements of our
evaluation methodology is something we
call brain strength
and a lot of people again measure how
strong a brand is what's unique about
this our brain strength methodology one
of the things that makes it different is
that it starts on the inside
so we don't just measure how many people
know our brain how many people would
recommend it what's the mps score we
start by looking at the brand on the
inside do people internally actually
understand it commit to it and we felt
that this notion of inside and outside
is actually something that applies uh
beyond just looking at how valuable a
brand is
that on the outside we all have
perceptions of what companies are doing
we all have an idea whether that's
fitting reality or not is a separate
issue but we all have an idea of what a
brand is doing uh in terms of its
environmental impact and then there is
the reality of what they're actually
doing the equivalent of our internal
measurement and so our methodology from
the beginning was going to really help
us understand what is that performance
what are companies actually doing
and what are the perceptions what do
people on the outside see as a result of
that
and obviously both of those elements
together impact what we all uh see and
and how we experience uh those brains in
terms of performance uh we wanted to be
very comprehensive we looked at the
number of things that's measured we
looked at what's important and we wanted
to make sure that we don't only look at
the products and the impact of the
product even though that's incredibly
important but that we understand the
supply chain and the stakeholder
engagement and how the governance around
it actually works uh and whether the
operations of the company are aligned
and all of those things are
actually based on publicly available
data so none of the information that we
use here is private
we look at what the companies are
publishing either in their
sustainability reports what they are
telling uh carbon disclosure project and
other projects what they are
including in their financial statements
so all of this is is highly quantitative
and it's something that deloitte helps
us with deloitte calculates this because
they have a great deal of experience uh
in that space
uh and we
worked together with deloitte to
determine how important each of these
factors is so we do put a little bit
more weight on the actual operations and
what the product and the actual impact
of the product but we take uh really
over 80 metrics for every brand into
account when we evaluate them
on the perception side
we decided to uh take a different
approach from some of the other
approaches and really go and ask
consumers because at the end of the day
uh we know that there are perceptions
around what the brand is doing
around the financial community there are
perceptions that regulators have but at
the end of the day we as consumers make
that decision to purchase or not
purchase a product to engage with the
service and we wanted to know how to
actually consume receipt and we wanted
to go beyond the easy markets it's not
it's it's kind of easy to look at
consumers in north america and europe
and come come up with a conclusion
we wanted to make sure that this is a
global study and that we actually look
at the 10 biggest markets by gdp because
these markets both uh carry a
disproportional rate in creating the
problem and potentially solving the
problem uh and the one nice thing about
that's kind of a byproduct of looking at
the 10 biggest markets by gdp is that
you have all the bric countries in here
so all the major regions are represented
so you have a nice geographic spread and
a good idea about what's happening in
developed versus developing markets and
in each of those markets for each of the
brands uh we uh
got we wanted to have a significant
sample that actually rates the brand so
overall each brand is rated by at least
1250 people we had an overall sample of
20 12 000 people obviously uh many of
these people evaluated more than one
brand
and in terms of what we looked uh for in
perceptions uh we leveraged that brain
strength methodology that we had and we
used the exact same same idea the exact
same dimensions but we uh really
translated them to the sustainability
space so for our brand overall it's
incredibly important to be
differentiated we didn't look at that
overall differentiation here we wanted
to know how differentiating our brain's
environmental activities
whether they are actually credible when
a brand goes out and does something is
it authentic
do people actually see what's happening
do they understand what's happening do
they feel that what they're seeing is
consistent and at the end of day is all
that relevant to them does it actually
matter to consumers so those were the
dimensions that we looked at but overall
when we looked at performance and
perception from the beginning we knew
that ideally we would like companies to
have great performance and great
perceptions but the reality is probably
going to be that one of these is
probably higher than the other now those
brands that have great performance and
not so great perceptions are incurring
an opportunity cost they're doing really
great things they're not telling the
great story people don't know about it
and so they're not getting the value
from what they're doing as much as they
could on the other hand there are brands
that have great reform or perceptions
and their performance is not necessarily
fully there and and it happens for a
couple of reasons sometimes uh brains do
this on purpose they tell stories that
they think consumers will like and and
they
kind of ignore the fact that we live in
the digital age and they expose to them
themselves to risk they green wash um in
other instances there are brands that we
simply assume are more efficient than
they are we we have a certain perception
we think that they're doing great things
and it's such a great brand they must be
doing great environmentally as well and
so even though our brand is not
necessarily actively building these
perceptions they benefit from people's
assumptions that they do in either
context that gap is not a great thing
and when that gap means that the
perceptions are higher than performance
a company is exposing themselves to a
significant risk and we penalize them in
the score for that
so this the the ranking this year uh
looked like this hopefully we've all
seen it already the number one brand uh
was toyota and uh as a matter of fact
that's been the case all three years
that we've done the ranking
and uh if you haven't seen this list
before then you're probably noticing
that there's a fair amount of automotive
brands performing really well
as as there are technology brands but
there are brands from all categories
really represented
and
automotive is by no means the only
category that's doing well
so i'd be happy to talk about the
details of individual industries and
brands but i wanted to leave more time
for questions and one and discuss one
thing before that uh in addition to
measuring all the brands we wanted to
also use the fact that we are talking to
12 000 consumers around the world and
see how their attitudes may be different
one of the things that we noticed as we
were measuring brands when we compared
results from different countries we
noticed that the same brand doing the
same thing is getting more credit for
doing great things in places like china
and brazil and india
than they are in places like germany and
japan and part of the reason is uh in in
some of these markets environment is not
just one of those things that it's nice
to talk about it's a true existential
issue you walk out of the your apartment
and the air is polluted and the water
may not be safe to drink these are
things that people face on daily basis
in markets where this is the case and
the governments are not necessarily
doing much about that when brands do
something about it they actually get a
fair amount of credit if you from the
consumers when you do the same thing in
germany the consumers don't necessarily
give you as much credit because
they kind of assume that you had to do
this anyway because the regulations made
you do it already so so that was
something that was curious to us and we
wanted to see what else is different
across these markets so we asked people
about a series of questions around their
attitudes around the environment uh we
purposefully had some positive ones and
some negative ones and the first thing
that we found was well not surprisingly
people say they care about them that
they think that the environment is an
issue so that's a this is just a kind of
simple heat map so green means more
people rank this as an important thing
and so in pretty much every market
people say that they're concerned about
environmental issues but notice the
other two statements they think that the
easy way to deal with this concern is to
just adjust a little bit or purchase
decisions so
yes environmental is
issues are a big deal but the way to
solve them is probably by just kind of
adjusting what i put in that shopping
basket
when we asked them whether they would
actually pay a little bit more
for those products that are
environmentally
conscious notice and hopefully you can
see the difference here in color the the
red here means that it's less important
so orange really that you're seeing here
in the uk and the us means that fewer
people in really the the richest markets
uh would actually pay extra so people in
india
and russia are actually pretty happy to
pay a little extra or at least say they
are
whereas those of us that have higher gdp
per capita as opposed to overall gdp
i don't feel are a little reluctant to
spend more
we had a similar question that was about
economizing and we were looking for this
agreement here and we were hoping people
would say oh no no i'm actually more
interested in the impact on the
environment not economizing and that's
the answer we got again in russia and
italy and brazil but notice again us and
uk people actually don't agree with that
people are actually focused mostly on
that benefit to themselves and their own
enviro economic situation before uh all
any of the other concerns and then the
last thing i want to point out is we had
a couple of questions where we hope
people would disagree uh but but the
percentages that we got around whether
people think that they can trust the
information that comes from the
companies and whether what different
companies are doing is actually
different there's a great deal of
cynicism about this so between a third
and forty percent of people in every
market say that they don't necessarily
trust the information that comes from
companies so that's one of the hurdles
that that brands have to overcome as
they are looking to leverage the great
environmental things that they are doing
is the fact that there is already an
expectation in the marketplace that all
of these are not necessarily
as trustworthy as they would like to
so be left some time for questions from
i asked a couple of questions and then
we'll have mike's go around
some questions from you all
um thank you very much for that emma
and the uh my first question really sort
of comes out of your picture of the
different brands where
five of the seven best performers were
automobile companies
there are a lot of people at this school
and the environmental community say oh
automakers they're not really
sustainable so you know
what is it that's driving them to do
things that meet the criteria or do your
criteria need reshuffling
so i think there's a couple of things
they
they're doing extremely well on
perceptions a lot of automotive brands
have figured out ways to really maximize
the impact of what they're doing on
perceptions and one of the the tactics
that we've seen a lot of
is uh focus on a hero product if you
look at the top of our list toyota uh
they were the first ones in the category
actually to come up with a hybrid and so
the entire notion of a hybrid ford for a
while was really tied to prius as a name
and and toyota got a disproportionate
amount of positive associations with
anything like that if you look at other
brands like nissan
leaf and even uh ford that did really
well this year number two they don't
necessarily have a hybrid or an electric
car but they uh talk a lot about their
ecoboost engine that actually that is
named
appropriately and that also saves a lot
but i think it would be unfair to say
that they're simply smart marketers
because a lot of these brands are
actually doing really well on
performance i think the another question
that it opens up is
what is potentially the role of
governments and regulators in this space
because the auto industry has over time
improved dramatically
the product that it's making if you if
you look at the the consumption per mile
consumption of gasoline if you look at
the quality of the factories a lot of
this has changed and improved uh
dramatically over the years partly
because they had to partly because
certain parts of the country of the
world were pushing them to but uh while
their performance uh is not always
number one they are actually performing
really well and i think if you if you
look at the totality of what they're
doing even though yes gas guzzlers still
exist uh the industry has actually done
a really good job of adjusting
that's really interesting the hero
products concept
and the impact on perception let me
switch from an environmental aspect to a
social aspect of sustainability for a
second and we were all
shocked by the collapse of the garment
factory in bangladesh in the spring
and you know lots of questions about
customers of those factories what are
you all seeing in terms of consumer
behavior and perceptions of brands in
those situations and
the concomitant responsibility of global
companies to prevent such tragedies in
the future
i think it's fair it's very obvious that
brands cannot hide behind the supply
chain anymore uh so
a lot of the brands got called out after
bangladesh and and rightly so and and
stepped in and tried to deal with it but
i think what we've seen not just in that
instance but
with a number of factories that treat
their workers less than uh great in
asia around around asia
is that companies whether they whether
they actually own that part of the
process or not consumers are actually
holding them responsible for it now so
they can't necessarily hide behind that
anymore in our performance metric we
include supply chain as part of that
because we think it's important but i
think what's more important is the
dialogue that exists and and the fact
that uh
when there are problems with that supply
chain you you should expect to be
exposed and therefore proactively
managing that is probably a better risk
mitigating strategy and probably a
better business strategy than waiting
for problems
yeah
another angle that was sort of
interesting about your methodology was
some of the really large companies you
you have their the name of the overall
company is different than the names of
the multiple brands underneath you know
can you talk a little bit about what
you're seeing in that regard both from
the point of view of you know can a one
company have brands that have terrible
environmental or sustainability
reputations and coexist with those that
don't or how do you go about sort of
increasing the system performance of the
overall company
when you have so many individual brands
uh so so part of the reason for that is
is kind of how the methodology is
structured and we obviously start with
the best
brands that are not necessarily always
company brands but you're right there
are companies that have a whole
portfolio of brands that we're
comfortable managing that portfolio in a
way where maybe a small portion of that
is dedicated to people who care and then
we have the majority of products where
we kind of just ignore it and then maybe
we have another portion of the portfolio
that's trying to address another niche
uh audience and and i think what they're
learning is that while uh managing a
portfolio like that can be efficient the
overall organization has to have a
strategy that then comes to life
in different brains and while you can
flex it in a way that makes sense for a
certain type of a consumer that doesn't
mean that you can necessarily give up on
the standards with other products
because those consumers don't care as
much yet
because they're uh we're clearly in the
process where uh more and more people
are learning and discussing and one of
the things that uh i didn't necessarily
mention earlier on but that plays a role
in our organization is seeing the
millennials and and the expectations
that they bring to the workplace the
questions that we get asked in the
interviews these days are not just about
what you do
as a brand and who you work with but
what is your foundation doing and how do
you actually help the world around you
and and so that's clearly uh something a
trend that's not going away and i think
managing a portfolio in a way where you
ignore part of the issue is probably not
sustainable
no pun intended
let me focus on the millennials for a
quick second as well um a lot of the
companies are technology companies and
they have you know wonderful innovation
models that are constantly turning over
there is a
worry on the part of many people in the
environmental space that lots of
incremental improvements are not going
to be enough to make the the changes we
need to have and how we consume things
and what kinds of products and services
we buy to make a real difference in the
world you know what's your sense about
whether
the innovation models technology
companies are are inventing and the
customer pressure for innovation might
lead to some real breakthrough or will
are we more likely to see sort of
um incremental innovation
i i definitely hope so uh i think when
we lo when in our assessment when we
look at different technology companies
we see a difference between those that
uh
really engage with hardware and those
that don't necessarily and actually
we're seeing some great performance for
from uh some electronics manufacturers
and and really brands that actually
produce things i think there is a
perception and an expectation that uh
companies that don't necessarily produce
things that you touch physically but
operate uh in the information technology
space there's a perception that those
companies are somehow sustainable more
sustainable because they don't produce
physical things and that perception is a
little bit more generous than reality
because what we ignore is that in the
process of of uh storing information of
collecting it there are literally farms
of of of computers and servers that
utilize a lot of uh energy so there's a
there's a movement in there to to change
things and i'm very hopeful that that
those breakthroughs will help push us
further
it goes back to the waiting slide that
you showed you know where do you weight
the off-site
impacts upon which you rely
uh in offering your services and for a
lot of those that those are operations
of that company so you can't ignore it
so speaking of
operations of companies and impacts on
them you've been doing this now for
three years
are you seeing companies that are making
big changes in either their performance
or their their efforts to change
perception as a result of this
so i'd say uh
we originally really wanted to encourage
a lot more transparency in how companies
are reporting and dealing and talking
about
uh what they do and then uh really a
better integration of what they're doing
in terms of sustainability into their
overall brand strategy and business
strategy and i think we're seeing a
little bit of each uh hopefully we'll
see a lot more but we're definitely
seeing uh that
reporting is improving that there is
more transparency that there's more
emphasis on numbers and not just stories
uh it's not consistent by any means but
but i think there's a
slow shift in that direction and we are
also seeing that brains are trying to
articulate and figure out
where does this fit because the initial
reaction with some of the companies uh
is sometimes
all of this environmental stuff is great
it doesn't necessarily drive purchase
therefore you know i i'll just kind of
keep it in on the side and we're seeing
that attitude evolve and people
understanding that it may not
necessarily directly drive purchase for
everyone but there is a growing segment
of consumers that it actually does dry
purchase for there is a whole set of
ways in which uh these types of policies
and actions are impacting uh the brand
and the business and they're kind of
starting to integrate that uh
some of the brands that we work with are
reporting more some are using it in in
their communications we've seen
kia use the fact that they are in our
ranking in their actual advertising in
canada uh but uh we're looking for um
longer term changes and i think that
they're coming so what's your hope for
this kind of an analysis
in the future are there areas you'd like
to see you the methodology reflect are
there impacts on companies you'd like to
see obviously we want to have inner
brands brand be expanded but you know
what's more generally what's your hope
for the future of all of this
i think we'd like really to bring all
the people in the organization uh
to the table together one of the things
that we learned in the process is that
organizations often have a person that's
in charge of environmental questions or
or a small department and those people
somehow tend to sit separate from the
business strategy definitely separate
from brand strategy and and one of the
things that we are hoping for and seeing
emerge is really a dialogue and
something that allows us to really not
treat sustainability uh both in
environmental and social context as an
appendix as something that we do after
we've done all the other work
but that we uh think about it and think
about all the actions that we're taking
from the beginning as a part of how we
see ourselves in the marketplace
cool
so there's some
mics over here maybe
great
hi i'm susannah harris i'm a first year
studying a masters of environmental
management at the forestry school i have
a question about the information
gathering process behind the best global
green brands report
you mentioned that you use
sustainability reports that companies
put out as part of the data
sort of inputs for
your equation
and i'm curious about how you make sure
that you're getting unbiased data and
how you really compare apples to apples
when companies put out such different
types of reports some that are very like
you said numbers heavy some that are
more storytelling
there are some initiatives to sort of
streamline and standardize global
reporting
but that's not really fully fleshed out
yet so how do you make sure that you're
getting really good information
especially when it comes to you know kia
using this in their brand and setting
themselves apart and getting that sort
of competitive advantage over other
brands you guys have a big role to play
in that how do you make sure that you're
really putting out the best ranking
possible so from the performance
point of view we uh decided very early
on in the process to only use publicly
available information and so and we've
had a number of conversations as you can
imagine since where uh companies would
reach out to me but we are doing all
these other great things that you take
that into account
and and the answer is does anyone know
about that outside of your organization
well not necessarily but we would be
willing to share data with you and
and and our answer is publish it and you
know talk to a journalist don't talk to
us once you publish it then we'll see it
but we're not interested in private uh
kind of collecting private information
we're happy to leverage the the carbon
disclosure questionnaire but i think
there's a lot of things that like that
already and so the goal is not to go and
kind of create yet another channel for a
specific set of data points now pulling
all of that together in one methodology
means that uh we do favor quantitative
information over qualitative so so uh it
it's easier to to us for us to assess
if we have actual numbers than if we
have a story and that's reflected in our
methodology through the fact that those
companies that tell stories and don't
also provide numbers uh don't get as
many points necessarily so so i think
that's
one of the ways and we would certainly
hope to encourage transparency in the
future through this
questions in this side of the room
in the middle
hi my name is angelo lam a second year
mem student at a forestry school
i was wondering considering the
ranking system that contains
companies that cross different
industries and sectors i was wondering
how how how informative is the ranking
order in a sense that if we see that the
toyota is ranked
in front of uh let's say coca-cola and
they are from different industry and
sectors can we interpret it as
toyota is a better or more sustainable
company compared to coca-cola
so i'd say brand more than company or or
a company that that that knows how to
leverage what they are doing so within
the performance methodology you're right
uh it's kind of unfair to compare uh to
it would be unfair to measure different
industries uh all together so so there
is the level of measurement that happens
within the industry and then there is
the cross industry comparison from the
perception size uh aside again uh we
will look at these dimensions but part
of what is relevant for uh cars is
different from uh what what consumers
find relevant when we talk about yogurt
and so we we let them tell us uh what's
relevant to them and then therefore
weighted different industries
accordingly so uh i think that the
notion here is
yes you're supposed to be able to
compare all of these brands regardless
of what industry they're coming from
partly because the measurement is
designed to account for that so uh so
yes the part of the conclusion would be
that toyota as a brand
is uh doing a better job
so just to pick up on that so that using
toyota and danone for example denon uses
fewer toxic chemicals than toyota does
probably in making yogurt versus cars
how does that show up in the methodology
so it's going to show up in a in a
number of of things inside
the slides here but uh when we look at
the operations the types of
questions that we're looking for are
obvious and the types of the metrics
that may be available are different when
we are looking at transportation for
brands like both toyota and the known
it's actually transporting products for
financial services brands it's uh they
don't necessarily have tons of physical
product to transport but how do they
choose to deal with commute do they
facilitate that do they minimize the
business travel and and so on so so
there are elements of that that are
measured within the industry so that we
can actually compare apples to apples
and and then compare the cross
industries and if i remember your chart
correctly you had higher weightings for
operational impacts and for product
related impact so it would right show up
there as well
other questions yep
front
and then will you get there hi uh vera
meyer i'm a first year mem at fps and um
i was wondering about those companies or
brands that
perform well but don't communicate well
is there a
type of communication you see
communication strategy you see us
systematically failing
i feel that the disconnected approach
that we see a lot of is is what
systematically fails so or um i think
that
the one thing that's successful is when
companies are actually able to connect
the dots for consumers so to actually
show what is that instead of uh you know
beautiful uh landscape commercials that
show
wind blowing and and and you know
flowers growing uh they if they show
what they're actually doing and how is
that impacting people and how's that
reflecting in the actual products that's
what we uh need to understand and so
that's why companies like automakers are
or a lot of automakers are successful
because they don't show the big picture
uh
you know things that people may or may
not care about they they show the actual
product that that links to what you do
uh uh well ge sponsoring uh this series
of talks uh obviously had a very very
successful platform a few years ago the
eco imagination platform that wasn't
just a uh an advertising campaign that
was an actual platform where they had
goals commitments and products aligned
with that that made it real and so
uh the more that the organizations are
able to make it real that and there are
many ways in which they can do it their
brains that are born green if you will
that that or sustainable uh that from
the beginning had that ethos there are
brains that do that through hero
products their brains that do it through
platforms there are different ways of
doing it but i think at the end of the
day it has to be uh real for for
consumer the big picture impact without
the actual uh thing that i i see and
touch and use uh doesn't necessarily
resonate so can i ask a follow-up
question on that you touched on this
briefly in one of your charts about
the difference between selling to all of
us buying cars and businesses selling to
other businesses
you know your advice to businesses
mostly doing b2b
work
do you suggest they emphasize different
parts of their performance or how do
they
best make use of this kind of analysis
and their sales efforts so so in that
study that you're referencing that i
showed some results from we had a number
of different industries and we looked at
both b to c and b to b audiences what we
found was that the impact on purchase
for b2b audiences was actually higher
than for consumers so uh and
as we compare different industries we
noticed that the more considered the
purchase is
the more important the impact is so if
i'm buying a car
uh the the environmental impact actually
plays a much bigger role than if i'm
buying a chewing gum
and b2b purchases for the most part are
fairly considerate it's a big chunk of
somebody's budget it's more money than
we spend often than we
when you purchase as a business than
most of us spend as consumers and so
these decisions are highly considered
and a lot of thinking goes into them and
therefore this actually tends to play a
bigger role
hi my name is will georgia i'm a second
year master of environmental management
student at the forestry school thank you
for coming
i was wondering if you could talk about
people's perceptions of the food and
beverage industry as i noticed there's
like coca-cola has a significant gap
between perception and performance
whereas pepsi has virtually no gap but
it's ranked a little bit lower could you
kind of talk about people's
perceptions of those companies and maybe
just the industry in general
i think that the industry in general
probably has a very very
high variance when it comes to to
perceptions and performance uh some of
the brands have over the years made an
effort to to talk about themselves
in a way that makes consumer uh assume
that they are stewards of of the
environment whether that's necessarily
entirely uh true or not and some of the
brains simply benefit from a very strong
uh brand overall and i think coca-cola
is is one of those brands that just
gets extra credit for for being as a
great brand that it is and and people
just assume uh that it's doing a little
bit more than it's necessarily doing and
then you know putting uh
polar bears on your cans doesn't hurt
if you if you know with those
perceptions
uh but i think that as an industry
there's a really big variance in and i
think that industry probably more than
many has focused on communicating
benefits when they can
and
otherwise kind of relied on
enjoying the benefits of branding
overall
one of the interesting aspects of
thinking about the cokes and pepsis of
the world is their dependence upon water
water quantity and water quality and
watching them
work through
various new organizational forms for
engaging in the watersheds where their
bottling plants are located
are you seeing that come up at all in
your work or in in customers are asking
for those new sort of broad or how do we
how do we position our company for
managing these resource systems upon
which we depend
and i think that this is one of those uh
things where where you are in the world
actually plays a huge role so in india
this is a huge issue and a very real
issue for consumers who uh really want
to be able to use the water and not go
and buy a processed uh product and and i
feel both well a lot of companies in
that space coca-cola and pepsi and
nestle have done a lot to to reduce
their water dependence and they're all
working towards water neutrality so so
that's a really positive movement but
it's something that is largely driven uh
by the situation outside of this country
in in in the u.s most people are not
worried about uh
how much water goes into producing a
bottle of coke they care more about how
much calories come out of that
depends on where you are in the u.s
any questions i've been ignoring this
side of the room but i can keep going to
this
yep
hi my name is emily grady and i'm a
first year mbm student as well um and
i'm curious about so a lot of the
companies i think um have had some sort
of
most of their initiatives have been
voluntary there have been probably some
government regulations involved
but i'm curious if you see any role for
like a government regulatory platform to
sort of lend legitimacy to some of the
branding efforts that these companies
are putting forward in the environmental
space
i i think the government
and i thought automotive industries is
one example of that i think the
government uh definitely has a role to
play i don't know if that's necessarily
on the on the branding side of things
because i think i mentioned uh
sometimes in in markets where the
government actually does play a fairly
big role that diminishes the brain's
ability to to uh benefit from from that
and kind of get additional perceptual
benefits if you will in addition to to
what the um some of the hardwired
benefits maybe
but then part of that is also how how
different industries are leveraging that
and obviously automotive industries an
example that uh
has found a way to kind of go beyond
what they had have to do and make it
something very successful
i think it it
certainly uh helps
uh
push the
thinking forward
and and i think one of the things one of
the reasons why i wanted to look at the
global companies like this is that you
can have an effect even if you don't
have a consensus globally right
if if a certain set of markets are are
requiring uh different things uh you can
imagine other markets lagging behind for
a while but not forever and so once you
see better products and more efficient
products you you kind of
want to bring them to other places as
well so i think
industries in general
should probably
spend more time
figuring out how they can push it but
but when that doesn't necessarily push
things as quickly as it should the
government can certainly speed things up
other questions yep
hi i'm alex apostolopoulos from the
school of management first year uh so i
was really interested to see how some of
those
attitudes of consumers break out across
different regions of the world i'm
wondering if there are any other metrics
that that you guys found interesting so
whether it was age
influencing perception or maybe income
level
any anything else that would be of
interest to us
so definitely we were very interested in
how does this look for millennials given
what we are all experiencing with
millennials and one of the things that's
interesting um
when you're just going to break the
numbers is that it's not a systematic
effect it's not like all of these scores
are higher for millennials it's really
kind of considered things so some
millennials claim to be uh more
concerned but then they're also more
cynical than the than the rest of the
population
they they are not necessarily in that
group
when we have those questions whether
they're willing to pay more they're not
necessarily going to say yes i actually
do want to pay more but they they are
more likely to say that they would avoid
companies that have bad reputation or
that they don't so it's it there's
definitely an age difference there's
probably an income impact as well but
it's not systematic and it's not uh
across all of those
ask a follow-up question about
millennials and and the
possible impacts
in the early days of corporate
environmental reporting
some of the companies that were most
involved said it's great for our
shareholders great for our customers but
we're really trying to attract young
engineers who care about sustainability
issues we want to be able to hire the
best talent in that pool is that an
argument that you see
reflected in your findings or in the
questions you're asking or in the
discussions with companies about why
they may be spending time in
these messages i think that's something
that definitely resonates and that we
certainly hear when we talk to companies
uh and and they are sometimes baffled
themselves because they come to campuses
like yours and they talk to students and
and they um
sometimes they may be in the food
industry and and feel that you know
ultimately they're doing the the right
thing and then they see
uh chemical company that is talking
about the
social responsibility in the right way
attract the the top students and they're
baffled by that because they feel that
you know inherently there's a difference
but they're certainly
realizing that and it's it's a big
factor these days
glad to hear
any other questions
one question i had uh was that a
question
hard to see against the spotlight hi my
name is yessania and i'm also a first
year at the forestry school and i had a
question regarding
your definition or how you approached
the idea of sustainability and green how
is it that you sort of define that with
this particular study and then also did
you
encounter any sort of problems with the
way that sustainability and or green is
perceived in different parts of the
world in the different countries that
you carried out your research
so as as interbrand uh we we really
think about corporate citizen kind of
the notion of corporate citizenship
that's broader than just the impact on
the planet so we think uh how our brains
treating their employees how are they
treating the communities where they
operate how are they treating the
governments that they deal with uh how
are they uh
treating uh
and then planet as one of those so so
for this study we chose to focus on the
impact on planet but when we think about
what that means and what it means for
brands we we also have a broader point
of view we chose to focus on the
environment because it was uh something
that we felt was um on the way to being
measured and who's in the uh
where we could understand the impact uh
better because uh on the performance
side there's a whole set of metrics not
fully aligned not fully agreed on but
there are there's a number of things uh
that we're already looking at and it's
something that has uh been discussed uh
and that consumers are familiar with and
they can uh think through but part of of
of how we rate those metric those things
that we measure in the survey is a
function of what people tell us matters
to them so we'll ask them uh
in the automotive industry for example
there are all these things that the
company could be spending their time uh
doing they could uh focus on creating
better products more efficient products
they could
focus on recycling they could be thought
leaders and help educate the communities
and
and then we ask people to actually tell
us which ones of those
which which of those actually matter for
automotive company and which ones matter
for
a food company and it's not always the
same and so
we actually rate what they tell us
afterwards based on what matters to them
in that industry
but in the in terms of kind of defining
it is is the impact on on the planet
that we focus on in in this study as
opposed to kind of impact on communities
that they operate in for example
is that
so just thinking about those different
buckets that you're working with the
communities and the employees and and
others do you are you seeing a sort of
natural weighting by customers across
those different buckets that's different
than or in addition to
what you described earlier across the
countries
where people
generally will say impact on community
customers well general as part of brand
analyses will say impact on communities
usually outranks impacts on the
environment or on employees or
one of the reasons why we started with
just planet is it's not necessarily easy
for consumers to detangle all of that
so often what you experience in your
community outweighs uh
the big picture or uh what you see
around the environment outweighs you
know the fact that you read an article
three months ago about the corruption
scandal that that company was involved
in so i i think uh
sustainability is one of the concepts
that consumers uh have
a little bit better and firmer grasp of
and i think overall when we think about
corporate citizenship there's still a
fair amount of of
overlap in in people's minds and and i
think in what companies are doing too
yep
any other questions
so speaking of
what companies are doing um i would hope
that in a brand's production of this
report would lead to interesting
consulting projects for you all or
interesting you know specific company
projects without asking you to violate
any confidences
um can you tell us anything about sort
of the most surprising project or the
most interesting project that's come out
of these
reports so so
ideally of course we were looking to
engage companies but the primary uh
reason for the study wasn't really to to
go in and get more business uh we
obviously do work with companies uh
to to help uh
really think through
their approach to sustainability as a
bigger picture
branding question and i think in that
context the question is usually not just
how do i better communicate the things
that i do as a sustainable company but
also how do i integrate everything i'm
doing there with
the other activities and partly here
the fact that we are giving to the local
communities that we are building for uh
the children of the workforce and and so
on how does all of that play together
and those are the the things that are
most interesting to us really bringing
all of that to surface and pulling it
together and figuring out uh
what what is the story that we are
trying to say how does that fit into how
the company sees itself and therefore
goes together because often
you you have great companies do great
things as kind of side projects almost
right and and not everybody knows about
that and then being able to to think
through all of it together and pull it
together is is something that we enjoy
doing
well thank you very much for your
efforts to pull all this together it's
one of the things we talk about a lot
how do you measure
environmental and sustainable
sustainability performance and the
methodologies that you have and the
transparency you're using are a big help
in in giving people something to which
to react to say wow great or geez i
think i could make that better in
various ways or whatever so if you all
would join me in thanking emma for a
time with us